how's it going bros this is beautiful I
am in New York for the YouTube summit if
you don't know what that is I don't know
either I don't know why I'm here but all
I know it should be pretty exciting I'm
gonna meet up with a lot of cool people
today it's 7:00 a.m. so I'm gonna go to
the gym for an hour to waste some time
and I'm bringing you Bros along it
should be a fun day all right so these
are all goodie bags for other youtubers
so the whole hotel is rented out just
for youtubers thanks appreciate it rule
number one of exercise it only counts if
you share it on the Internet I didn't
realize they had pounds in America I was
like Jesus Christ I'm so [ __ ] strong
it's pretty pathetic anyway I feel good
so YouTube got me a gift
hello oh sorry what do we got here I'm
boxing with PewDiePie welcome to New
York
we're pumped to have you here this week
is going to be action-packed check out
the attached schedule cool
o ultra moisturizing
I hate moisture adult coloring book I
hate I hate coloring books for a default
YouTube what the hell man you said you
would get me Swedish licorice I'm so
disappointed I get this garbage I'm
sorry thank you very much I really
appreciate it thank you
this has been unboxing with PewDiePie I
hope you enjoyed now i'm gonna unbox
myself if you know what I mean oh
someone is that the door I wonder who it
could be
oh yeah touch my front yes let's say
guys happening all right Jack would you
like to smash me what a smash in the
iTunes version pillow no yeah yeah yeah
it's time to confess my YouTube sense
you know I want to be that guy what are
we doing what are you doing what no
thank you
yeah my name is mr. booth what is your
name mr. sleuth Chuck tack that dog just
now
which one of you is PewDiePie he Becca
this one would you rather wear pants
that make a whoosh sound every day or no
pants at all no no two of you do your
best impression of PewDiePie on a roller
coaster stuck upside down the spiral as
you look at the spiral see a ton of your
games keep staring at the spiral
oh oh oh [ __ ] Oh
oh my god oh it's a and sweet just relax
the lace young give me volunteers a mess
around we were asked to make a taco but
we made this this is a creation this is
not huge on made it out that's the best
for Nelson accident that's all right we
need a name
what's the name if you put a name in the
comment you could win this one comment
right now the winner will get a gift
sign and a stop and a peach inside
I got a few don't tell me what I'm gonna
do it I will do it I will demo
I'm tastiest taco tape your psychosis he
can live outside the box
having gracious is the worst competition
I hate puck now wait now Jax stupid team
won look at that [ __ ] [ __ ] I hate
it
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] look like a
[ __ ] deodorant I want to waste a
thing you have the best power but no one
wants the trophy keeping all right cool
think your [ __ ] alright well clearly
i won hey at least I don't have a
cooking show
[ __ ] channel you can kill this guy
right now so fast do it do it
[ __ ] okay first of all I know
you guys don't doubt for a second that I
could beat them both up at the same time
right now oh you want to put that to
that yeah let's test it
play Ohio man meet you want alert aah
ultimately use your hound on the groin
just as fast as we can and that's how
old women yeah
pounding on the groin is just gonna make
me common can you say that on your video
what do you think I do they found us
they know who we are sorry all right I
haven't bought anything I'm sorry we're
heading to the party now I know what's
happening we're going in the bus just
like the good old days
yes should I close this door or close it
close automatically I'm so sorry
hey Bros my voice is really dead last
night was really fun today I have an
interview with Times magazine
it's really cool I want to show you all
right so times 100 most influential
people I am the only one from Sweden
hey and there I am feel like she'll
break a pewdiepie and it's written by
Troy Parker I don't know how this
happened but when I saw it I was just so
happy it's such an honor
especially that Troy wrote it that
really means a lot I think it was really
cool it's gonna be a hard one to be
anyway now I'm doing an interview for it
hopefully they're not recording my voice
cuz Jesus I hear about it Suns um I got
a pack super fast just want to say I met
a lot of really cool youtubers at the
summit everyone was so nice and so fun
to hang out with I had a blast thanks to
everyone I met here in New York I love
you you were awesome thanks to you guys
for watching this vlog if you enjoyed
leave a like
I appreciate chat stay awesome rest